what's going on guys this is rob and we
are finally here with the onslaught
revelation yes we are the one-shot comic
with a full-on return of onslaught and
marvel comics and at first glance the
story's a little confusing but when you
read it a couple times it's actually
just an amazing story right so the
overall gist of this to kind of get you
guys caught up a little bit and then you
take a few seconds here the overall gist
of this is that onslaught had basically
returned as what amounted to a kind of
psychic entity right in the sense that a
portion of itself existed and basically
every single mutant that had died and
been resurrected and that was
exceedingly important because we don't
really know exactly how onslaught got
there we simply just know that he did we
can largely assume or at least we get an
answer in this story but up to this
point we largely assumed that it was
just kind of a the small little remnants
of onslaught existing in the minds of
xavier and magneto because that's how
onslaught really originated in marvel
comics right xavier's frustration with
humanity's refusal to co-exist with the
mutant population and magneto's hatred
of humanity merging into a singular
entity that basically unleashed holy
hell on everybody on earth
and almost conquered the whole world and
so onslaught returning comes in a couple
different forms the first thing here is
that it was nightcrawler in legion who
initially picked up on the fact that
this was happening nobody else seemed to
grasp it it was by virtue of the little
things they were getting involved in
people struggling with their powers or
people experiencing a kind of emotional
turmoil or something like that and while
legion was the person that would help
with that along the way he started to
realize something's influencing people
right something is influencing these
various individuals who have died and
come back and so ultimately working with
nightcrawler they realized it was
onslaught and that charles xavier is one
of the people being controlled by
onslaught as well as magneto himself and
so you end up finding out that with all
these people who are being controlled
here one of them includes pixie now
pixie is one of these weird characters
on marvel comics right she is a person
that has the ability to manipulate magic
marvel's never really done anything with
it and even the the theme that marvel's
kind of gone with is that at some point
doctor strange will basically tutor her
in terms of being able to use her
magical abilities at the moment right
now it's just a few things that happen
there here and there she's not a major
threat to anybody and in fact she's one
of the easiest to manipulate in terms of
psychic attacks and that's why she's
been brought here because legion is
basically using his mental abilities to
essentially overrun somebody and then in
turn use those abilities or at least use
that that method to basically drag out
onslaught right to make himself you know
make himself relevant here make himself
prominent and that's kind of the crazy
thing because the desire of onslaught
here is that because he's been feeding
on what is in effect the life energy of
those mutants who die and are then
resurrected those small little fragments
of them because that's happened to so
many people it's allowed onslaught to
grow stronger and that with onslaught
basically controlling all these mutants
that his desire can't simply just be or
at least the the goal uh to come back
can't really just manifest in him just
killing everybody right because then
there would be a kind of mental fight
between these mutants themselves and the
power of onslaught instead the easiest
thing to do here is to get them amped up
right to get them excited right to get
them hyped and so what's been happening
at least what's going on at the moment
is onslaught is basically getting them
to party and i know it sounds crazy but
as most of you guys know just having
been at parties yourselves that in a lot
of ways inhibitions go out the window
especially the more excited the more
amped up you get and getting them to
that point where they're just so chock
full of energy that in turn onslaught
can use that and then just drive them
all to kill each other that massive
influx of energy this that's created
when they die would be enough for
onslaught to come back in a physical
form and if that were to happen
everybody would die right there'd be
virtually no one that was capable of
stopping onslaught and so what you
actually end up getting here in the
middle of all this is of course you have
lost and you have fabian cortez now
these two are basically the focal point
right they're they're the the two most
important people here and the reason for
this is really based on the idea that
fabian cortez had killed the parents of
lost and we talked about that before
right that lost powers they're her
ability to kind of manipulate the gravel
gravitational forces around her that she
had uh their parents had been killed by
fabian cortez when he was part of the
acolytes just kind of an attempt to sort
of solidify the the threat that they
represented things along those lines
right just kind of carrying out a
campaign where fabian cortez initially
tries to rebel and tries to stand
against you know legion and nightcrawler
and these guys we end up finding out
that they're actually in the mindscape
of legion and because they're in
legion's mind his powers reign supreme
here now this is in stark contrast to
the way that we've normally seen
legion's mind depicted that whenever we
see the brain of legion what we actually
end up seeing here are these instances
where legion's mind almost kind of looks
like a prison and each one of his
personalities are housed inside a
different cell as part of that prison
right that was one of the coolest things
that took place and the legion's
storyline is part of x-men legacy where
basically all those personalities
escaped right so legion literally had to
round up his personalities but as for
pixie herself the other reason why she's
really kind of been liberated here is
given her soul dagger right her ability
to kind of tap into magical energy what
it does is it allows a kind of override
of whatever's going on in somebody's
head if they're being mentally
controlled by somebody else and so by
going through and essentially stabbing
people in the head
using basically her uh her
you know soul dagger that it in turn
liberates them from the influence of
onslaught the problem with this is that
this is no small feat right i mean this
can't be done with every single person
here because the amount of time it would
take is just simply too long and that
they basically have a countdown to
midnight when everybody just essentially
ends up dying here and so as a result of
that you actually end up having a kind
of bit of manipulation on behalf of
nightcrawler as he's talking to fabian
cortez and he says actually cortez
you're the reason all this happened in
the first place right with onslaught
coming back and all that kind of stuff
you're the reason this happened and it
seems kind of strange because you
wouldn't expect that connection to be
there instead what you actually end up
finding out here is that fabian cortez
represents this kind of you know pompous
nature right as my crawler describes it
ambition defiance always you have turned
toward the front of the shoal right the
school of fish you've always looked for
somebody more powerful than you to latch
yourself onto that person and to raise
your stature in the world but it's time
for you to put away your pride and do
the right thing here and that's when you
get this kind of admission from fabian
cortez in the sense that like he's
always hated himself because that's
always been his thing right regardless
of the the the life he's had for himself
regardless of who he's been he's always
kind of played second fiddle to a degree
right things have just been given to him
but it's never really been the story of
fabian cortez right his power is to
basically boost the powers of others and
as he describes it there's no starring
role for fabian cortez no heart stirring
arc spoiled brat answers the call to
revolution learns humility and heroism
he says people ask why i stuck with my
human name he says the reason why is
because nobody wants to throw a parade
for captain mcguffin in the end i
figured if i gotta be the bridesmaid if
i gotta always be in someone else's
shadow then i better pick the biggest
damn shadow i could find and that's why
he latched himself onto magneto that's
why he was the leader of the acolytes
and served magneto with such loyalty
because magneto at that time right and
you look at like x-men volume 2 in the
early 1990s was just this massively
imposing figure right just this clear
and present danger to the human
population because of past exploits
right where he issued a blanket-wide emp
and shut down power to everything on
earth right just different things along
those lines that if magneto chose to he
could actually end all life on earth
right just the level of power that he
possesses but the whole idea of fabian
cortez is if if i could live up to
magneto if i could even imagine that i
was him right by being the person who
boosted his power being the person that
made him such a prominent threat that i
could argue i made magneto therefore i'm
the star of the show magneto is able to
achieve these levels of power because i
made it possible right if i put him on a
pedestal it would lift me as well and
all this is really just kind of a giant
you know instance of him dumping this
this kind of level of humility that he'd
never experienced before and all of it
comes to bear with regards to his
admission to
lost now during that time of course
pixi's basically trying to track down
magneto and xavier she manages to locate
magneto right hits him in the face with
the with the soul dagger and frees him
of onslaught's control and then
basically xavier bales right runs as
fast as he possibly can but the reality
is kind of switching back here to uh to
fabian cortez as he talks about this
like he basically says like he's never
really believed in anything right that
he's never really seen himself as
anybody who was worth anything right he
lashed himself onto people who were
better than him because it was the only
way he could really see himself
developing any measure of self-worth and
in doing this he basically offers
himself two loss right ask for
forgiveness says i'm sorry you know i'm
i'm i apologize for what i've done and
what it does is it allows lost to
forgive him here's the reason why that
matters because on the surface that
seems totally irrelevant in comparison
to like onslaught coming back or any of
that stuff it's one of the most
important things and the reason why is
because as one of the portals kind of
opens to the mindscape and all this kind
of stuff goes on they actually end up
traveling to like mars and all kinds of
crazy stuff right while this massive
party and this whole thing is going on
what nightcrawler reveals is that the
story that lost told right when her
parents died that she was adopted by an
organization and she was experimented on
that organization was orcus which as you
guys remember from just following the
x-men mythos they're the organization
looking to destroy the mutant population
and that what orcas had done is they had
realized how much hatred lost had for
fabian cortez and that in her hatred for
fabian cortez and in her desire to be
accepted her struggle her history the
entire mutant population would accept
her into krakowa and so what they did is
they took that small portion right that
almost kind of psychic entity of
onslaught as small as it was and they
bonded it to her if onslaught could
essentially be weaponized or turned into
an actual substance it was put inside of
her and what she was was essentially a
trojan horse right that little sliver of
onslaught was put in her she entered
kokoa and then in turn because she spent
so much time among the babies in krakowa
and those individuals who were basically
being resurrected right trying to find
some sort of meaning for herself
onslaught was able to enter into the
resurrection protocols so that every
single time a mutant died and was reborn
onslaught could siphon and put a bit of
himself in them but the whole idea is
that it was latched on to her hate by
her forgiving fabian cortez it's removed
that and so now the entire influence of
onslaught in terms of its anchor to
hatred which in turn allows it to
influence everybody else it's basically
gone right he quote unquote cured her is
really kind of how nightcrawler
describes it but the influence of
onslaught in the minds of everyone goes
away and onslaught just kind of emerges
as this basically you know unanchored
psychic entity that's out there and the
first thing it does is bond itself to
charles xavier right the first thing it
does right it basically says if
anything's going to be done if you're
going to do anything you got to do it
yourself and so the crazy thing about
this is it actually ends up being legion
who basically saves the day here not in
a traditional battle not in the sense
that you see legion using this vast
amount of energy he has and attacking
onslaught head-on and the reason why is
because if he did it would almost mean
certain doom just because of the fact
that onslaught can absorb individuals
and so in any kind of a moment it
doesn't matter what it is that onslaught
could immediately seize legion take over
him and all his personalities probably
exercise uh you know a level of control
over legion's personalities that legion
wasn't able to do himself and so now
you've got onslaught running around with
what is basically omega-level telepathy
and telekinesis and then on top of that
legion's powers and the thousands of
other powers that come with it right he
would basically be elevated to near
god-like status so much so that he would
probably be able to dominate and destroy
the entirety of the universe if he chose
to and so what you end up getting here
is soraya right now dust is a really
really cool character and while she's
not the most important person in the
entirety of krakowa she is here and the
reason why is because one of the major
powers of dust is the ability to convert
her physical form into what is in effect
dust itself she's also highly resistant
to telepathy which is the reason why
onslaught was not able to take any
measure of hold on her mind but what
she's able to do here is basically
convert the bodies of everybody in this
place to dust so they can't physically
be destroyed by onslaught while that's
going on legion basically unites all
their minds together and then it comes
down to nightcrawler who actually ends
up essentially forming a religion that
what he does is that with all these
minds united it's basically a page out
of adventures of the x-men number 12.
from back in the the early 2000s or the
1990s those of you guys who don't know
what that means it was basically the
collapse of the multiverse right that in
adventures of the x-men that the dweller
in darkness had basically tried to try
to destroy everything in existence and
pretty much succeeded but in order for
the dweller in darkness to be defeated
the phoenix force united the minds of
everybody in perfect harmony so that the
dweller in darkness could not feed on
their fear now of course again the
collapse of the multiverse couldn't be
stopped and that's where the origin of
galactus comes into play and all that
stuff but that's basically what happens
here that nightcrawler kind of uses what
he refers to as the spark this sort of
meditextual concept he's been alluding
to over the course of uh the the way of
x stories and then really solidifies it
here and essentially saying that with
all these minds united and what isn't
affect happiness and and you know love
and care and all that kind of stuff risk
all that you know the whole nine yards
he basically says that that everything
here right that these people who have
their minds open to these ideas that in
their their i guess love or or what have
you that it basically allows for the
destruction of onslaught right that
onslaught is essentially the antithesis
to love right onslaught represents
hatred he represents rage and that
because he's simply just a psychic
entity at the moment albeit bonded to
charles xavier that by them sort of
uniting their minds in that capacity
using the power of legion it quite
literally dwindles onslaught down to his
most pure form which is just this small
little tiny parasite looking thing which
of course is destroyed by by uh
nightcrawler but this is important here
and the reason why is because what
nightcrawler has done is effectively
created a new religion under the idea of
the spark right a kind of belief system
among those in krakowa that the nature
of cocoa itself up to this point is that
people have kind of treated death as
something that was kind of reckless
right they could just die and be reborn
and that was it right but a lot of the
familial ties that had existed before
and even a lot of the rivalries that had
existed before had been maintained in
some form or fashion instead what
nightcrawler looks to do here is
basically have a kind of police force so
to speak for a cricoa itself in the
sense that it is policing the minds of
the people who were out there right
ensuring that nothing like onslaught can
happen again and it basically comes in
the form of the legionnaires now exactly
how this is going to play out we don't
fully know we simply know the tagline is
they keep the peace they keep the law
right they keep the spark so again it
kind of seems to be a sort of psychic
police that maintains the kind of unity
and love that exists in krakowa the
downside of this is it could go really
dark really really fast but that's
something that i do want to kind of
specify here is that if it hadn't been
for legion onslaught would have won
right this was by all standards of
measurement a fight between legion and
onslaught just not really in the
traditional sense having said that i
kind of would have wanted it to be like
a traditional fight right just raw power
on display
the truth is you couldn't really do that
in a one-shot comic you would need
something a little more complex to make
that happen but at the end of the day it
is cool onslaught's return was
interesting it's kind of disappointing
that it ended in this way i kind of feel
like the return of onslaught really
should have been an event more than
anything else because of just the level
of power that he possesses like a more
updated and modern onslaught saga that
would have been more compelling than the
original one was if that's even a
possibility because literally the stakes
were as high as they could get right
like the universe was at stake
but it would have been cool to see a
more updated version of the the
onslaught saga having said that i
enjoyed it right i thought it was pretty
cool but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end the new
arc for legionnaire starts i have no
idea when at some point just says coming
soon but thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]